[Music]
hi I'm Toby and welcome to another
episode of the joys of mathematics today
I'm not going to throw any formula or
equations at you I'm just going to tell
you a story now behind the story you
might be able to find hidden away in
there the essence or some of the
intuition behind calculus but don't
worry because this is not going to be a
mathematical story this is going to be a
story about a guy called Bob who lives
in a little Hut in some snowy mountains
so I want you to just sit back and relax
and enjoy listening to the story don't
stress too much about trying to turn
your brain on but hopefully you might
learn something along the way so like I
said this story is set in the mountains
now it's a very windy and stormy day in
the mountains we've got a lot of wind a
couple of things happen though which are
not ideal the first one is that one of
the trees one of these little happy
trees on the mountain over here is
blowing over that falls not such a happy
little tree now the second thing that
happens in the windstorm is that a
little section of the bridge which is
made of logs here and connects one hill
to another over a river it breaks away
and falls what it's left in its place is
just a couple of wires that used to hold
the logs together the logs had broken
off don't fall straight down into the
river but they are blowing sideways a
little bit to this grassy meadow down
here okay so all of this goings on sort
of concerns Bob who lives in his little
Hut and he comes out to check that
everything is okay it's true Bob yeah
now this story is about the links that
Bob goes through to do the right thing
now the reason he's so concerned and he
comes out of his Hut as he knows that
down here in the middle where the wood
has fallen this Meadow are a couple of
deer who are very dear to him
there are a couple of friends of his and
he's concerned he wants to make sure
that everything is alright and that no
one's been hurt and down in this meadow
now to be able to get down there and
check he's going to have to cross this
dredge of logs now obviously the problem
with that is that a section of the
bridge is missing Bob's gonna have to
come up with a plan he does have one
idea in mind and that is that looking at
one of these fallen trees beside him on
the hill he thinks he might be able to
use that tree lay it down a long wire
that's left in place on the bridge and
we collect a little ranch for himself to
rip down now there's only one problem
that Bob really needs to consider about
this plan and that is that you know
we've got a curved bridge and if we lay
a flat tree down on this wire that part
of the bridge there is going to be
straight and he doesn't want it to end
up being so steep that he just slides
down it and isn't able to climb back up
to get home you know bob has also some
very old shoes that are completely worn
away on the bottom so he doesn't have
much friction coming from his shoes one
thing that Bob knows from past
experience is what kind of slopes and
ramps he is able to walk up with these
shoes of his now obviously walking a
long flat ground is going to be easy
walking straight up and down a wall is
going to be impossible but what Bart Bob
does know is that exactly in between
vertical and horizontal if I was to draw
a line exactly in between them there
that is the limit of how steep around
Bob can walk up with his shoes without
slipping okay so if we know that this
little flat tree lying down here on the
ramp is going to be as steep as less or
less it'll be fine there'll be no
problem so Bob needs to check and the
way that he's going to measure how steep
the little tree ramp would be once it's
on the bridge is that he picks up a
pebble now I've got one here by the
camera
and he holds the pebble to his eye and
he looks at the hole in the bridge and
he just uses the table to measure as
sort of a measuring stick how many
people's he think could fit in the area
vertically between the missing logs so
if we had a little triangle this is one
log this is the other log these are the
missing logs that would have fit in
along here and this is the wire that's
just in their place holding them
together he measures how many pebbles he
thinks with his I could fit down here
and how many could fit across here now
what Bob measures just by using his
little pebbles is that he thinks he
could fit three pebbles in this height
and three pebbles in this width what it
means for us is that our slope is
exactly as tall as it is wide it also
means that it's exactly the same as this
line here because this line here is as
tall as it is wide so if everything is
fine and our pebbles were a good little
measuring stick then a little straight
ramp here should be just deep enough for
Bob to be able to handle with his shoes
so let's go ahead with it Bob's pretty
strong and he carries the tree down to
the slope and puts it in here so now a
section of the bridge is our little tree
but it's pretty easy to cross over so if
you're here to learn a thing or two
about mathematics and what we just did
is differentiation we had a curved line
which is our entire bridge and we found
the slope at a point on our curved line
just by zooming in on an area of
interest and treating that area as a
straight line in fact in this case we
had a tree in there so this section of
our curve was treated as a straight line
and we found the slope at that point so
let's keep going
Bob walks along the bridge and comes
down into the
Mido now what are in the mid air are a
couple of deer let's try and draw maybe
one of those on the head might be a bit
hard to see so little legs for I don't
know if do you have a tail so Bob has
gone down into the meadow and the first
thing he notices is that all the deer
are alive the piece of the bridge hasn't
fallen directly on to any of them so
that's really good news
however what he does start to get
concerned about is the fact that quite a
lot of the grass down here is now being
covered by the section of the bridge now
it's kind of concerning because he knows
there's not too much grass down here to
begin with and he starts to think you
know maybe with this grass gone and
being inedible to the deer because it's
covered in a part of the bridge
maybe the deer are going to run out of
food Bob knows exactly how much grass a
single deer will go through in a season
so he knows how much grass is needed to
be down here in this meadow and because
the meadow is just a rectangle he knows
how much grass was there originally what
Bob really wants to know to make sure
his little friends are going to be safe
is he wants to know how much of the area
of the grass is now gone
he wants to subtract this amount from
the total amount of grass and make sure
it's still enough to be able to feed the
deer if it turns out there isn't enough
grass to keep them alive Bobby Pro we
have to call for help to move the
section of the bridge out of their
meadow or look for some other solution
so Bob gets down here onto the meadow
and he thinks okay I've got another
problem
this part of the bridge that fell into
the meadow is a really irregular shape
it's not a circle and it's not a square
otherwise I would be able to find its
area quite easily so he thinks well
maybe I can approximate this as a circle
or I can use my trusty little pebble to
try and measure how many circles would
fit inside this irregular shape now I'm
going to draw it up here to make it a
bit easier for us
see so this is the shape of the part of
the bridge that's fallen into the meadow
like I said it's quite irregular because
it's not just one log it's a few section
of different logs that have fallen kind
of looks like the shape of Australia now
that I look at it but that's just a
coincidence so Bob thinks okay I all I
know is how to find the area of
something like a pebble if it's
approximated to be perfectly round so
I've got a few of these pebbles I can
lay them out I can get them from the
riverbed and lay them along the shape
and if I take my pebbles and lay them
around maybe I can lay them on top of
the shape and I can just sort of count
how many fit into this shape now that's
one way you could do it you could count
up the how many pebbles approximately
equal the area of our unknown shape here
we have one two three four five six
seven eight nine pebbles
this might be an OK approximation if you
find the area of these nine pebbles you
can just say that's the area of the
shape but you know it's not perfect we
have some overhang here so we're saying
that this area is part of the shape when
it isn't we've got some gaps in here
between the pebbles because they don't
perfectly fit together and whilst this
is an approximation it's very far from
perfect
so what Bob can do to get a better
approximation of this area is to get
some smaller pebbles now if he lays some
smaller pebbles on here there's going to
be less of a gap between the pebbles so
less area that's not being measured and
when a pebble does overhang it doesn't
go too far off our area it's still not
perfect we still have a bit of overhang
we still have a bit of gap between our
pebbles but we're getting a bit better
so there we are that's what our new
measuring technique would look like
we've still got a bit of area in here
that's not being measured correctly by
these pebbles we've still got a tiny bit
of overhang but it's definitely a lot
better than what we had before yeah this
might be good enough
people but Bob he really cares about
this dear and he doesn't want to take
any chances with approximations he wants
to know exactly will these creatures be
okay will they have enough grass how
much of their grass has been taken away
from them by the bridge we really want
to know exactly okay so this isn't good
enough for Bob he looks around him and
he sees the riverbed and he sees it it's
made up of sand now
sand I guess you could say is a very
tiny tiny pebble Bob knows that the
smaller the size of the item he uses to
approximate this area the more accurate
it's going to be so he thinks to himself
you know it's worth it I'm going to get
the sand Bob lays individual grains of
sand and little columns down the shape
and he has to count exactly how many
grains of sand he's placed he knows the
area of each grain of sand because
they're perfectly round grains of sand
and he takes his time to lay them out
one by one grain by grain along the
shape it takes so long for him to do
this that while he's laying them down
it's no longer day it turns to night and
then it turns to day again and then it
turns to night but Bob keeps going
because he is really dedicated to these
creatures and he wants to do what he can
to be as accurate as possible a couple
of days later we are all done it's back
to Sun and we've completely filled our
shape with grains of sand if you ask Bob
how many grains of sand he laid down on
that shape he might say it seemed like
an infinite number but we were just
getting very close to infinity there's
certainly hundreds of thousands of
little grains of sand on that shape but
the good news is that bob has an almost
perfect knowledge of the area of this
shape here so he pulls out his notepad
he works out the area of the original
garden he subtracts his now known area
of the shape here he works out how much
grass would have been needed to feed a
couple of these
dear down in the mid oh he works it all
out luckily he finds that even with the
amount of grass that's missing there is
still going to be just enough grass to
feed everyone in the meadow so this is a
really good news and Bob feels really
great with this peace of mind that
people are going to have enough to eat
with that Bob climbs back up the hill
walks across the bridge across our
little ramp made from a tree and he
walks home for the night II he had a
pretty big excursion but at least he's
happy that everyone is ok now what we
did here when we calculated the area of
the shape was actually integration or
the essence of integration what
integration means is that we can find
the area of any shape by slicing it up
into infinitely small pieces and this is
a pretty useful thing to be able to do
to find the area of any shape and to
find the slope of any line even if it's
curved so I hope you learned a thing or
two from Bob's little adventures and the
mountains today thank you for watching
this is your invitation to subscribe to
my channel if you'd like to see more
content like this and I hope you have an
absolutely mathematical day
[Music]